oh my god
[Music]
there we go
then it did it y'all right there you go
yeah now god I did all that yeah what
your face yeah but your gameplay you can
put it you can put it I or I guess I've
it I don't invite us let's let's go cuz
we don't have a lot of time with Griffin
alright squad oh that doesn't look good
though this is like Brady Bunch you know
yeah yeah and I'm working down right now
I'm looking down why does Steve and
cokes of places look like college dorms
Jesus hey young mine what's it what's
about one picture you got behind you
Griffin what the [ __ ] is that hey I just
did dude I'm telling you I [ __ ] hate
pub G I just started the game without
even doing anything I don't even know
well let's get one game of G because
because because Greg hazard
and we got 19 viewers right now I see
people saying destiny in the tent there
also you jest you see [ __ ] yes right
yeah
Craig [ __ ] man
test me is life yeah I'm starting it up
right now I have to go to the comedy
store tonight I could swing back over by
the guys this place when I get down to
bring this out oh well just hold on -
tonight we'll hook it up later cuz I
think Steve's gonna go somewhere after
so I will talk oh this does look great
yeah we should have Oliver I think I
think you should be different like on
that side there I think all of our
Twitter's and stuff should be right
there oh yeah yeah
Brendan and cokes yeah no that's not
that fine I didn't say [ __ ] oh I thought
he said cokes I was like why would I
give a [ __ ] how it could play Craig's
the one that knows what's best for the
podcast show me your body that's pretty
good body and it is the Year John Connor
Steve can we guess that Steve's quiet
man what's going on to get his luck he's
trying to get his life together my life
my love my life my light level
that's a good idea tonight man but what
about time to try to set that up it'll
be over is it like a auto-rifle steam oh
my god bless you Arthur
I can't must well maybe it's a good
thing all right let's uh
Jesus why's that thing so long for me to
load into this [ __ ] Griffin's already
in it's probably cuz you're hosting dude
just uh when you get in just invite all
right are you no no no I can't I can't
just fight get in that [ __ ] and like
it's not I feel like it's not what oh
gosh you're next boxes new Xbox 2020 is
the rumor all right Pikachu invited I'll
just join Arthur all right send me one
oh this is telling you this is the one
we finally did it
[Music]
Kraig's banana now everybody can compare
how much better my game play is Steve
join us stealing Griffin's kills yeah
you're here we got outspoken we got a
[ __ ] side-by-side how much every time
it's gonna be like god coke I feel
really bad for you
I'm sorry you have to play with
[Music]
this is what we're doing this is this
Frank textin in the chat got-damn in
that love pub G yeah it was Frank's P we
just be honest at Frank's know we've
known it for a while next time we'll be
like hey Frank I pop the fire
I can't believe you don't have that see
I really have I really can't believe he
doesn't have the destiny yeah because it
just makes everything so much easier you
know 2029 is the worst yeah leave it up
to the people to see who is Clovis prey
that's a new rule like a different
person in the lead sometimes yeah we're
gonna see their delay that's weird
yes today I'm gonna go I'm gonna go I'm
going to be Kobe baby Oh from the side
blanket
oh [ __ ] I'm what to die oh my god this
game heavies about yes so much capturing
this son of a [ __ ] see watch I gotta
[Applause]
they're coming around they're gonna try
coming to see good should get you good
nice thinking
no no oh
[Music]
Angela your vigilantly Sherando so deal
of saying there's a weird lag echo i
don't know why that be is anybody's
computer on or anything affected oh you
know make sure not also make sure your
audio your game audio's turned down that
could be part of the problem
oh you know be my TV yeah yeah all over
my life oh yes my TV ok can I lost my
[ __ ] heavy feeling with that [ __ ]
[ __ ] me [ __ ] I got the guy inside
alright let's get another zone oh my god
anyway swings now they may know I don't
want this Dom play once in the middle
their team shoot that face humbly come I
got him I got nice I might have to
switch to my dog boy [ __ ] that guy it
slams I got the bad cop yeah there we go
oh he just stole my kill another dog
wait whose dog blade is that that's
there's a shop crash there's gonna be
yes what's coming your way home dawn
blade nice
well this is my warm-up game is that hey
alright yeah where's he coming we got we
gotta get we gotta get his own
oh now that we got the role like where
we go
yeah right now we're playing serious
been trying to get flawless forever
I just got wrecked
- up top - up top I got one hurt your
friend is liable a lot what neato I
don't even get a kill off
come on let's turn off the stream with
the wind we can bring it back and you
down by 13 they're taking see though man
we need to I don't know is that we need
some zones you know I don't know either
I got one off see there's another one
back here though god damn it man there's
two over you captured let's find a fee
cuz they're gonna start spawning on one
side [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that's no good [ __ ] you with the [ __ ]
whatever that was he's hurt
Griffin how did that guy get past you
there's no way there's guys sniping
they're all at B let's just go pray and
see cuz buck beat I got a golden oh come
on oh [ __ ] that's terrible
oh and I got killed by a random fighting
line Jesus Christ
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah okay I meant to switch
to my walk my warlock
what are you playing with my hunter ha
nul a dog Lee
okay nicely got 101 we gotta get his own
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow
they're absolute driven he was an
absolute yeah that's how yeah oh I still
kill them
I mean we're done this is where not one
in this one it was getting some warm-up
there's a warm-up why'd he kill me yeah
who's the culprit who was it all right
all right Katie well second best was no
you got 4.2 you have the second place
how did you become in some random dude
we are pretty bad best you know what
Steve no that's not fair to us we're
good okay they're bad oh no Steve
[Music]
[Music]
but I thought up until then had some
good stuff I thought later yeah what's
her name was really good the lead
actress she does a great job
check it out it had like I didn't see
Incredibles - okay I gotta see that Oh
put the booty was off the chain let the
girl go scratched oh yeah you know what
scratch you're gonna make your you're
gonna make your red skin horse [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm watching him scratch his arm
when he's all sunburn with the
strawberry that
I'm sorry general Craig is in the
background we've decided we didn't want
to put his face on the screen can you
turn that down Steve thank you
yeah I'm sorry you can see what it looks
like though right yeah open up a new
window open a new window and shear this
actually yeah yeah yeah will you do that
you make the layout all right thanks for
trying to upgrade a little actually be
like oh I think we do yeah I think it
makes
yeah yeah we're not gonna be well all
your twitches and Twitter's and whatever
but it looks good
Luud out Midtown eight freefall well
what do they show I'm never gonna go
it's a gay hundred dollars a person it's
not take a hundred bucks dude I don't
get it
Oh everyone stand in there but I'm the
one that dies I just don't get it
guys are sneaky - oh this guy has a
[ __ ] where's three I promise you know
[ __ ] I guess so
and I'm wasted on with that rocket going
to see dude there's [ __ ] two three
people there yeah [ __ ] dead I hate
this [ __ ] math hate this on [ __ ]
math is so [ __ ] much everybody
[ __ ] scoping then nobody moves yes
this is a scout rifle map for sure oh
yeah he didn't die you finish it
survey one weak sauce weird audio
cutting in and out [ __ ] I don't know if
that could be problem I know or some
people I don't know talk what's up man
what's going on this game I'm not I got
nobody with me at all
Wow trying to go for hard do we want to
do do it do we want it in my restaurant
are you gonna make me red zone right now
no no no
we'll stop this [ __ ]
we'll stop this [ __ ] right now and we're
gonna do privates Steve I know I know
you're not it's a [ __ ] trick I'm
blaming I'm blaming you I'm not looks
like me crater Brian Midtown huh there's
a guy on be [ __ ] sin there where is it
correct yeah what is it
some of us are very really quiet when
people are listening my friend just me
who's quiet who's quiet my friend said
yeah you know can you speak we can't no
one can hear can you [ __ ] [ __ ] we
gotta speak up hmm here we go I can be a
weird speed up chipmunk effect sometimes
that I don't know okay whoa we gotta
troubleshoot that double shoot these
[ __ ] guys dude they both had [ __ ]
heavy I'm chasing both of them down
[ __ ] [ __ ] I mean we're going
through oh yes well that might be dude
it'd be deed I know I know I'm trying to
get over there watch out
so [ __ ] annoying dude they're saying
like a cell phone could be causing an
interference that's possible oh let's
probably Steve because we've got the mic
and the cell phone right up it's not
looking for game I want to see
everywhere how the [ __ ] it is
I don't go to see oh [ __ ] arc Strider
we're now Craig wants the same he didn't
want to sing that John Connor saw the
[ __ ] number probably he's probably
died
he's probably died like 20 times I mean
account if I killed its oh nice
get them hammers [ __ ] they got have
to kill me what what could I get this
guy Eric slam blueberries last bro we're
just [ __ ] we're not golden guys oh my
god we're not moving for zones at all
I'm watching everybody hearts go [ __ ]
lanes [ __ ]
nice go it's still 110 behind yeah yeah
I know I don't know what I was aiming at
FNC why does this what what the hell is
a dire promise taken I'm gonna take I
thought I was gonna take a but there's
dudes here there we go night
all right rotate rotate
Rosa [ __ ] [ __ ] them dude they're just
sitting there [ __ ] colony you need
oh my god so frustrating it's [ __ ]
gay I could do one more man this guy
taking a Wow it was hard to catch up
there but let's see whose fault it is
this time Craig okay Craig was around
the house
Katy ain't even [ __ ] close to mine
set the [ __ ] down oh whatever
look at more cancers - you piece of [ __ ]
I got more kills got one and Steve
actually got you got one second best KD
we got 40 viewers right now guys yeah
cuz we're the worst we're not gonna
where can we we can win what a way to
start this thing play out out so I'm
truly how much I can suck
oh man you guys hear about those updates
they're making for the exotics make it
something so they're on the app right
now what they're doing is they're so
young Makara spines they're taken away
like the mark that it gets when you
damage them
they're making they're gonna make
tripmines last longer they're gonna last
longer that you're gonna be able to
throw them faster and they have a bigger
black spray I'm pretty fun who comes up
with that stuff I don't know but I mean
what was the point of they needed to
buff it cuz no but no cuz it's a stupid
[ __ ] exotic it doesn't do anything
it's not as it's not as good as it
wasn't what else are they both whoa uh
lucky raspberry they're increasing the
chances getting your grenade back which
is completely under way so to put all
these mods yeah
zombies they're upgrading stompy so what
works for triples off so I said when are
we doing a 24 hour stream now with
everybody past 24 hours stream you're
out of your mind
yeah yeah my t-shirt Steve this guy says
you have the sick would drag cuz of
taking down David show he said coax
should watch out for you and that's
talking about when you wrestled show in
the dude could you know it would be the
best fight of all time beat me up with
this [ __ ] pink you have you guys
thought his muscles
[Music]
he picks it up he goes oh that's
probably they're all oh that guy right
now behind you behind you [ __ ] hurt
bro I'm coming but I got Merle I walked
into four of them
no plan you don't this on app call any
[ __ ] all right we need yeah there
are you know let's just get CNA know
because they're too far no they're too
far like what we're not gonna be able to
keep those this is an annoying group
they're all just mom would tell you to
you know hold hands hold your brother's
hand you know what they are they're
holding hands
I took Kayla come on we got to come on
come on a half faith once the gut about
come on we got this come on boys we got
this week they're gonna keep her his own
advantage rolling for down only for down
yes we have those own advantage I'll
hold this position yeah
yeah yeah heavy I just had heavy I just
waste there like a piece of [ __ ] follow
this guy all right I got to now with my
slam there's one more guy over here we
go
when we take care of it everybody come
on there's no there's no come on
least if we go for a night I'm taking a
oh my god [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
dammit where are they there we go I'm
getting dude I'm getting [ __ ] there
it beat there we go just let the whole
place alright when I have to leave -
it's just getting good
come on let's win for Griffin wait let's
not we're not talking about where we're
going or what we're doing we're just
talking I'm happy
everybody push P get B no just hold
tight
there we go there we go if you got a
super unit I got a switch to my [ __ ]
warlock when I get back [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] this guy's got this golden guy act
one more kill we're gonna add one more
kill for them that's not what I want I
like when Griffin is like anybody see
Jurassic Park who wants to see Jurassic
Park and no one no one wants to see it
yeah you didn't like hereditary what I
liked it I just thought the M was kind
of hokey hope not like there's some
there's a word good yeah Ulta kind of
cheap like cheesy is that better a
little pig fries pokey that's a P I know
you should know that brought everything
together were you like oh that was like
that you know I thought it was a toy I
thought was an interesting choice I mean
I liked a lot of film I thought you Toni
Collette was [ __ ] sick did she really
well and there's a couple really good
moments there's a couple definitely
creepy moments the sound as I was good
the clicking sound was good yeah that's
all I'll say but yeah I mean that there
was some good elements but you know yeah
and puffy
the biggest [ __ ] thing with punji is
the rendering issue dude that game like
they need to fix some [ __ ] on [ __ ]
council no so no so papaya
suck it I didn't give away anything
except for when the lizard people come
at the end of the movie okay we could
win this one we know this map dude oh we
know this let's do it we know this map
switch chair - I wonder who's gonna get
the best KD this time it'll be me
okay where you guys going to be go and
see ah I'm going to see them I'm
following code coca-cola's oka Colts
actually you do that I'm gonna try to
hold them off but they're coming this
way
you're getting a they're gonna come from
cave they're coming down on the right
side two of them one of them I think has
a fire yeah they have [ __ ] heavy
oh is that what it is right fighting
lines and oh [ __ ] yeah coke do you know
anything about definitely so now yeah
yeah I know I saw ya know oh [ __ ]
they're all coming - hey dude there's
like four there're a bunch
anymore all right I think we got rid of
most of them there's one more all right
well we can win this dude we got to yeah
we got this I believe in nothing I kind
of like that's cuz the weak link is gone
oh wait no no wait Pikachu still here
hit me okay I'm kidding I'm gonna no he
did beat you baby either by one I'd beat
you twice oh he did yeah I think he
would not 101 [ __ ] that was a terrible
rocket Brasil hashtag resumed the
current bashing there you go I love it
oh no they catching up dude oh yeah well
there's a guy up top on see Pikachu he's
above you against don't care what you
see you gotta come down well he's got to
come down and murder to you which he did
well I got some probably matter that's
truly an exit
really [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
there we go [ __ ] Maine angry but all
these people usually call and need Jesus
I know it's like everybody my
grandmother
oh we got this we're gonna win this one
dude watch we're also down a guy mate
they're down a guy I don't care I don't
get money no I want to win I don't care
I'll take the win I don't care about of
mercy I don't care I believe you though
watch out I'm gonna go over here I got
something for ya what one is that we're
bad let me get killed five kill straight
coca-cola yeah heavy get that heavy Oh
nice
I've seen enough come on say it and I
think it's above 3000 Dom blade coming
to see [ __ ] you got me so be captured
advantage I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna get a
car watch out this t-bone blazer yeah I
know I know
oh my god I whipped my good man alright
they're taken see oh yeah I do the
marketing I just started doing it for
them guys no [ __ ] watch out there's
people in the tunnels
main ingredient damn it
this guy's just hiding there behind see
[ __ ] dude get him get him
no nice afternoon afternoon killstreak
oh we're winning this 10 kill streak oh
I'm doing terrible
alright see my PC setup I don't know I
just got a new PC power for this degree
his PC set-up is it's ok let's just say
that it's not great no it's a cheap it's
a real cheap gaming PC but it's you know
something um
aha get them nice [ __ ] I'm Steve I
got it I got his heavy yeah oh yeah baby
frickin guy has a [ __ ] rocket that's
too nice coke I'm sorry I'll do that
bring back memories right here let's get
a let's just clutch it Hey now we're
hoping we're holding hands - yeah good
it's kind of actually not bad in the
best with some sword got golden did we
lose Griffin and look damn car eight
points easy pretty good yeah that's
pretty good - that's pretty good - card
you left Ruby - what's going on I had to
run back home I wasn't ready once we
stopped the stream or it yeah
oh really Blane Griffin it's okay
okay let's read chat what do they say
thanks night man
we did get for once actually one month
although they were shorter yes Steve you
did really good
thank you thank you will you meet with
my with my bow with my arrow I went
behind him like that you didn't know I
was there that was that we're talking
about that play
what's up sit see mom's just talking
about chuckling gonna make him a mom I'm
in playing far cry 5 man you guys would
really enjoy it I mean it's it's a
different kind of game it's more of an
RPG yeah yeah yeah far cry school I mean
I would play it but just got up hey
Steve would you play a match against
Griffin on the stream yeah yeah I mean I
thought it was it was a good fight
I thought he put it all on the line man
show a lot of heart and it's one of
those things I'll have respect for pop
just because the dude stepped away from
WWE already making millions he's just
really fighting me to do something
that's fun yeah super scary
my opinion super scary well this is the
day I got into it with people on Twitter
because people on Twitter were yeah well
we're they were saying cuz I said like
99% of people on this earth want to do
what's implemented and I had a bunch of
people like yeah right if they paid me
that money I [ __ ] do it it's a
completely different because there's
different variables one your you didn't
Russell on WWE you made millions of
dollars
yeah of course you're broke and I
working that at McDonald's is gonna go
fight for a bunch
and one a person would because you need
the [ __ ] money Punk doesn't need the
money so he - he took he took a pay cut
to do something that's that's that's
harder and it's real it's [ __ ]
written you know yeah
so you know love the pump will forever
have my respect man I think I think he
he showed that he didn't prove and he's
got a lot of puppy yeah give you a heads
up on a new contender up-and-coming kid
named Aaron Pico he's good he's looking
real good dude I've been knowing about
this kid for years when he wrestled for
st. John's Bosco have you heard of this
kid go whoo he fights their bellyful oh
yeah yeah yeah what's with the new deck
Steve what's the what's the mate it's a
Willy Santos it's the deck so shout to
Willy he gave it to me when he hopped on
so well nice one show us yeah trying to
work off the spat on my gut yeah I mean
I've done interviews and I've talked
about it but like I said dude like the
guy I mean he's still I mean he's coming
back and training like you just do that
cuz punk has that mentality like he's
gonna do what the [ __ ] he wants to do he
doesn't care what anybody else says and
that true church strongly successful
people and just and and people that I
respect think that way ain't [ __ ]
shoot Trump
yeah what what the [ __ ] up with this
map like why I don't like using I don't
know I don't like this yeah Anna
breaking suck getting the B sucks and
they're starting us on the same side
every time I think it's easier to get
there from a than it is from B I mean
from C to B that's [ __ ] cuz we have
all these like things in the way to get
to be you I could go around like seven
walls a just has to go into the right
it's kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] so Steve want
to know about the layout guys what do
you think of the new layout do you like
the new layout it's Craig doing a better
job that's not the question do they like
the lab is the question God it shows way
to like like a tooth Pikachu in and out
you know clean zone
well let us know if you guys like the
layout we're trying to switch it up here
oh man I ran right past I got a shotgun
I'm not doing good this match I hate
this map I really do not like this man
yeah we're not like yeah we can bring it
back though we can do this cuz you can't
this lanes to open going to end it out
they can see you a mile away oh my lord
watch out Steve he's got sword right
there there you go nice ah I like that
that's Pikachu's new line is are you
[ __ ] me are you [ __ ] looking me or
are you for real
the references oh my god yeah it's true
but I think my favorites cuz that's a
weird question to ask they will probably
know if they're [ __ ] more per favore I
like her safer potia raj's he's really
excited and the interest is Asian was
coming out I was just [ __ ] it was
there just now cooks better looking
nobody wants to see me on the layout
well hopefully next time we'll get we'll
get four of us up or something we'll
have more we're just testing it out
so be captured zone advantageous yours
good shot from every side here we can
bring this back we're not we're not work
as a team we open B is for a yeah that's
what I'm saying no I agree and stuff to
get there like a kill one guy over there
I'm going to hey it's trying to take it
from these days you got B yeah you're so
open when you when you hit that Lane is
what I'm saying I hate it
no I'm going I don't like doing any
careful worth Frank to flake yeah where
is thank you
he's this way he's at his job he's at
the Comedy Store
though the gun something wasn't a that's
me
Dolan game go to Nene Gordon game not a
game
the only thing go to game
take some zones voice which comes by
accident yeah I'm getting this is not
fun I mean I'm not doing well I'll tell
you what oh oh you got me maybe if we
could just control a and C will be doing
[ __ ]
oh is that guy doing god dammit Howard
play have a power play yeah yeah because
I was trying to take the two of them
came to see we're just not talking we're
not moving together I do agree those
this games this map sucks I'm gonna take
B [ __ ] you guys should play Goldeneye
oh yeah d it's a great game if we could
somehow its own way though I try to
split now you can't play it's not the
way it used to be like we used to think
it's awesome
now we're used to games like this it's
not awesome
I know I'm sorry the [ __ ] out of here
who's next
I got now we can do this [ __ ] [ __ ]
he know would me I still killed him are
you
are you [ __ ] me is that what you're
gonna say
oh oh that's my favorite thing you guys
said next all right you bring it bad we
got this on event let's play smart
they're like just they're just sitting
back there they're just sitting in this
on dude come on go coke kill them kill
them all man I hate this map so much I
like distant shores why can't we do
distant shores baby I know right yeah
how did that not kill that dude there we
go
that seemed like Pete hasn't her second
I got him there's a heavy on the stairs
by B if anybody's near there I got okay
we can happy we can win we can win okay
just stop dying as much all right a lot
about teams I got this fist I got it I
got through over here and there's fun
three okay it's time I'm taking C then
taking a we're taking see old B we got
we got this
watch out guy with a shot gonna be two
guys with like heavy it looks like a
beat
nice Peaks do it Peaks he's hurt her
there we go
I got him he drew up a [ __ ] shield
but I killed him through it I got that
guy there we go they're getting B
they're getting B they're getting be
contestants imma throw grenades off and
[ __ ] you look pleased actually a feather
to be their tether that'd be nice
but by sand nice nice nice to take a
little rolling gun [ __ ] you sir oh there
you go yeah there we go
nice alright three more bombs aren't one
more
yes we want yes we brought it back yeah
Mercy Me Baby 2029 is the year coca-cola
song yes I did better Craig that's all
that matters to me did it
barely you'll get Mickey Coke are you
gonna do UFC porn no no Steve Steve saw
that what time Vince you Steve UFC porn
no I don't want you upset porn man
nobody you saw a video don't even oh now
I know someone says does we really make
you better educate or BJJ weed makes you
better at everything sleeping and
everything
so how much would it cost you to do your
preform how much would you turn Wyatt
why not what I'm disturbed about is why
you're asking me this plus you know I'm
asking fun all a small Asian friend well
we got many small ears and friends so
Peter - I think Craig wants to seek out
Phoebe's I thought I was asking for pqc
he's not even helping us right there
we want to know how many times you I
think seven times talk to me how do you
warm it up it's ticking rustling inside
it nah I got some lebra dog his raw dog
indeed he's right but I do that that's
how you like chafe your peepee and
[ __ ] up dumb I stay at Craigs man so
next time I stay at Craigs
he tries waking me up in the middle of
night you know the deal is Amy remember
what we're talking about okay okay okay
why why are you embarrassed because it's
a human thing to do there's no there's
no shame and brother there's no shame in
it
makes me human that's all somebody you
gotta get send you so much so many
goodies dude I'm gonna hook you up so
hard dude I'll stop I'll stop
is it making you uncomfortable I'll stop
yeah yeah just make sure you sanitize it
you are you washing it are you washing
yeah you gave me this sanitizer no are
you washing it like bringing the [ __ ]
and washing it you are so I did not use
if I did all right I'll stop okay you
know it'd be good if Steve was like the
dude dr. Ruth Westheimer remember her I
would love that if you were that much
Tabor's like the noose dr. Ruth was like
this old Russian lady that used to give
out sex advice and she was kind of she
was big back in like the 80s like that'd
be hilarious so Steve was like the new
dr. Ruth
no illness oh I miss missile oh nice
nice coke
oh well that can't come from Oh what
he's right there Peaks oh geez I really
want that shirt with the flesh head says
it makes you human
oh my god I still want to wear that well
well chat hello yes things are
potentially happening we should talk
about that after after the stream
there's nothing man you know it's normal
we're still oh yeah
put up some once someone says something
inappropriate in chat after mod what
does it say
all our it so he said pocket [ __ ] yeah
what are you so [ __ ] is not blocked in
her chat
I almost had it and then that guy
[ __ ] shotgun Jesus segata if you
think all vodka there's a goddess or
come night behind Kenna me focus my bad
I was distracted by thank you for that
got my [ __ ] one I don't know how that
idiot didn't kill me but I [ __ ] him up
that was so stupid that I should have
killed bebe that was ridiculous
thanks for the heads up thought I
actually survived because of it [ __ ]
and then I died
I'm right behind you coke yeah well [ __ ]
let's catch before handing up two guys
yeah
nice Stevie yeah we can bring this back
mm-hmm I got that guy how about we go to
be you guys know being yeah we're trying
yeah I'm coming over there he's right
there he's behind you I know he's hiding
on that ledge right by B this is what
this is the dude that's annoying me
there's what he does I don't know yet
hold on I'll tell you a second I gotta
get over there
wow man I'm just getting murdered by you
don't [ __ ] that let's go for C dude
that's the problem we're all going for B
and C's really no we're all going wrong
we're all going for be on different
times yeah yeah I'm bossy too
where does the [ __ ] oh there's a guy
behind me yeah there see now they're
spawning over there put it on a nine
yeah when it be where his [ __ ] okay you
got him you got him you got amigo nine I
got him love each other on be careful we
are taking be [ __ ] these dudes there we
go there we go [ __ ] [ __ ] up calling me
calling me calling him be
oh look I should be dead now he's dead
thank you
there's an arc Strider over there
mark stop yeah you just caught me he's
coming to be okay where's this guy today
oh he's my other day he's been taken I
got the work sir
why is no one helping cook it be alright
let's the boys right anyway yeah it's
hard
there we go nice luck you'll hear a
little ledge little [ __ ] there we go
oh I thought that too is gonna get
someone take out purge 21 please thank
you
autumn oh yes he's where is this guy he
just hides Oh perch yeah I think that's
the guy they have a really good look for
African be
well you got to take them out before
they run into the circle because they're
just capping us when we get in there you
know guys are just sitting too far back
we can't push his own butt everybody no
one's here okay okay we're off here
we're just getting killed at different
times and running back in see like I'm
getting [ __ ] stopped by dudes I don't
think we're gonna win this I don't think
we can win this when it works you're far
behind here huh no we could still bring
it better well let's get seen you want
to get a triple play I'm coming that way
no yeah I'm not playing so hot right now
eighty eyelet setter careful I'm not
either dude
getting shot from everywhere they're all
oversea dude no way I'm playing terrible
this maps and all everything just
throwing me off
chocolate coming your way yeah yeah use
it use it or lose it
and there's two over there coke right
there they're hurt
I got a gun always set the wall [ __ ]
they have the tether they're two piece
of shits this guy's lying I played I
played so bad I'm gonna take B though
[ __ ] them
come on every time I turn around [ __ ]
ass oh my god
I really did [ __ ] sorry guys I've failed
us I don't know what it wasn't these
guys they're just there was a lot of
[ __ ] aji art staffing great ending
great ending my bad guys the [ __ ]
[Music]
northen are worse and Arthur foxy
alright I'm gonna step it up this next
sometimes I just don't want to be good
that's just the way it is that's just
the way it I don't like that map either
why not just ensure I want sure at least
once a copy yeah that'd be good huh so
what do you guys think about like
Pikachu getting locked away it's gonna
suck off Oh camera looks good though
yeah it looks good hey coke so you're uh
you're all red skinned huh yeah got
burnt like a mom today as no bueno you
guys get a lot of strawberries though
I've got a lot of things with
strawberries in them
I had a strawberry brought for the first
time what strawberry pie we had a
strawberry pancake strawberry bra
strawberry wine plan then I got some
there's some barbecue there yeah that's
about it but yeah a bunch of us are not
very brought tastes like is it good oh
it's actually really good it's actually
it complimented it really well I thought
it was gonna be too sweet for a bra but
like it wasn't really I think of
strawberries usually being a little
bitter like you know a sour sour yeah
it's how are the tartar tart
I don't know pens either ever if they're
ripe strawberries they're not tired
they're sweet which you like better
strawberries or blueberries that's hard
that's a tough one there's a hard you
know I like blueberry I like frozen
blueberries if you haven't tried like
this oh yeah freeze and blueberries
that's [ __ ] good as a snack breathe
for all your frozen yeah those are good
those are good I've gotten bringing this
coconuts back the other night Steve but
they were sold out you got try it
sometime I like that mango drink you
introduced me to of years a couple years
back all the lossy velocities are due
and we got to try these coconut things
they've been sold out time I've had some
so there's any other good movies coming
out I mean what else is coming out
you're the movie guy credit
I guess ant-man can't manawa spray yeah
what about games anybody because there's
a record Ames thanks streaming games
I'm telling you far cry 5 is damn good
dude it's so good alright what's your
favorite thing cuz last time like your
brother was telling you like how do I
like sat on mints and stuff what's your
progression now I'm gonna play Far Cry 5
it just I yeah I took over most of the
settlements in the first area yeah how
do you know that you were treating about
it
yeah big - no Stevie will you uh square
yourself up in the camera a little more
your lousy left of it that better well
you bought a sink I can't see it I said
Peaks who knows everything about those
it takes them in others yeah that's
better
they're they're one of my favorite
people now I'm Pikachu actually like
Steve has secret cameras everywhere
watching the Lee brothers no I
how do these guys just run away from
everything I throw up them nice come on
yeah this Maps a little better yeah
we're gonna get the full team now so be
on it I don't care what team the best
well I just took out two of them there
we go that's three down no wise sort of
a getting funnier than any swear word
Steve it's a what's up with everybody
using fighting lion now that's what I'm
saying this a but my remember isn't it
like you get it and then you get like a
buff I know babe I'm not playing you
know what my girlfriend's watching me I
say where's what your watches no it's
okay no you can watch I'm just saying I
feel pressured now I got a kick-ass
defend defend your woman through playing
destiny bruh
I'm trying to get a kill I haven't got a
killed yet no I haven't got a kill your
Craig
okay that was my first kill this [ __ ]
guy just back way back [ __ ] throwing
[ __ ] grenades at me he's by a oh
please I'm not last
it's a Cody Thank You Cody yes I did
No hey Crick's those hi mom hi mom
hey we're actually not doing bad at all
okay made no [ __ ] sense
nice good job that's Phil what are you
taping they're taking these fools let's
take a pass my face
Oh pop get golden get those all where
was that guy okay look he got heavy what
they often fusion it looks like I know
rockets
I mean grenades grenade launchers are
big again oh yeah yeah that guy should
be on being rock now I'm on bottom
damnit lost this to this dude so she
likes your girl's animations thank you
yeah man to buns [ __ ] these guys dude
you just got power play come on what the
hell happened killin no look yes
cameras color
is that God
where he was slam Venus and they're
bringing it therefore they're bringing
it back oh come on Craig I'm trying to
get my super going as I was about to use
it but I think a few times and I get
something murdered [ __ ] are getting
powerful and thinking [ __ ] like this guy
[ __ ] you [ __ ] your buddy
[ __ ] Jesco solar a good name alright we
took out most of the team in that let's
get through a rift and I shield down on
Wow play the game you just got more
heavy right now you know what these guys
are can't they what a winning let's get
it together guys what the [ __ ] is
happening it's my fault it's my fault no
it's all your fault it's my fault turns
on the bomb
I'm trying to get Jones dude nobody's
helping was own I likes that bridge in
Pasadena dude the place is dope I've
been there so many times I haven't
jumped yet though after this game I
might
[ __ ] God there we go mom there's another
guy right there you guys coming to be
got the time oh maybe they were just
[ __ ] with us the first half right
there no I'm the weak link survived
there we go
hammers I think there are see where
least five minutes
have a shotgun Jesus what happened all
he's so heard coke you can't [ __ ] I got
shotgun there you go
should we still do it or now there's
just a hard [ __ ] snipe
you got super [ __ ] unit does I do
you're gonna see that get angry I bet
your kid was a good game good game games
cranky you hold off a couple minutes
because my girls taking the showers out
okay gotta come in and check it out it
was Kurt's no crazy things going we
gotta talk about that thing oh Jesus all
right everybody no stone no rush Steve
well just let me know when ya all right
everybody it was a good spring
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]